there's been a lot of talk i've seen of
a four-day work week that seems to be
something that
that uh you've been focusing a lot on
lately i'll tell you from my experience
when i was working a desk job in israel
i worked
a normal office job five days a week the
whole nine to five
nine to six and i was that whole time i
was like dude i could
i could do this in four days easily i
mean
when you're sitting at a desk you waste
so much time
and i always thought that that idea was
brilliant because
it's got to do a wonders for morale
right i mean
have you been reading studies in
literature about that
yeah the data is tremendous around a
four-day work
week and it's also common sense because
work kind of expands to fit into
whatever time you have
you know what i mean like it might give
you a bunch of stuff to do with being
like you've got five days
it's gonna take you five days right if i
say you've got this much to do with your
four days gonna take you four days well
especially with the promise of an extra
you know week it's motivating yeah you
know in
israel we only have one day weekend
so you know what's funny when i moved
here i was like
this is like a dream i love the long
weekend
but um i started to feel like god i wish
i had one more day
and i started to feel guilty about that
and like
i really can't get enough can i like
wait wait tell me more so
israel like uh just as a foreign
which i'm guessing is saturday yeah so
um
sunday is the first day of the week it's
not monday
so that is wild how the like i consider
myself a fairly
worldly cosmopolitan person
and i did not know that yeah um
school is sunday through friday and you
only have saturday off
they go to school six days a week can
you imagine that hell
yeah all right i'm gonna say something
please don't judge me
um yeah i went to a prep school that had
classes on saturdays so i actually have
oh my god you can't imagine that and so
i can't imagine it
and it was not
i just read about it only recently
because you've been talking about it and
i
find the whole idea so interesting and i
think
i want to read more about it and learn
what it really means because we actually
have an
a business and we have maybe 20
employees so
we could decide to go that route for
everyone
but i would have to know like what
exactly it would mean
yeah you should look into it for sure
and then
maybe even run like a trial in your case
you'd run a trial but the data is very
positive where it says that
productivity uh either stays the same or
goes up
in the sense like you get the same
amount of work done
and then there are reduced stress levels
increased morale
like the people use that extra day off
in a way that they find restorative and
productive and like a you know personal
way
and so it's me it's like upside on the
personal side
and the on the business side of the
productivity side
uh there's really no loss and in some
cases there
they're positives right so uh and
to me society-wide too america in
particular and you guys have like a very
distinct
uh job if i do say so but
you know but like america generally has
this uh
this workaholism problem or
some one person called it workism which
is probably
like maybe a better name um where
keynes projected decades ago who said
we'll be down to a 15-hour workweek
because we'll be so rich
and it turns out his estimates of the
top line were right like we are as rich
as he said we were going to be
but our work we are actually migrating
longer not shorter
because of the nature of corporate
culture and the economy where it's like
you have to be always on
and um available and the work kind of
creeps
and that is what's happening right now
and it's driving health problems stress
problems
relationship problems you know like that
there are a lot of signs already that
the american work culture is kind of
morphed into something
uh not terribly healthy and so i think a
four-day work week would be a massive
improvement
for many many corporate cultures and i
gotta say like a lot of the times you're
you're there like you're not doing [ __ ]
no like you know probably like one day a
week you're just like i didn't
do [ __ ] today
i mean i was i probably was spending 30
hours a week on reddit
i've i've gone to pages of reddit that
men
have never even known i've been to
thousands
of pages back unknown pages of reddit
that was my job guys when you're in
israel you were like someday i'm going
to be a massive internet creator and i'm
going to spend my time
mining like the deepest depths of the
internet in preparation
yeah exactly you know in finland
in finland the prime minister had called
for employers
to allow employees to work not only four
days but
six hours a day so they are taking it to
the next
level that's some next level stuff
i might not i might not go to that that
extreme but but i like where their heads
are at
right now does not work yeah in finland
they're saying
no work but you know uh i'll tell you
what because
as business owners we're always thinking
about like morale and
you want to retain the good and the you
want to retain the talent and make sure
that they're happy and satisfied working
there so
i'll tell you what on a four day work
week i don't think anyone's going to
leave your
company you know i mean yeah i mean
it sounds like your moral and retention
would be very very high i'm sure
your staff that are listening to this
are like suddenly nodding being like yes
yeah i don't know i don't know if i can
do that for you dan and ian exactly
because we have a production schedule
what can i do i can't give you the
you know what i'm saying i mean i'm
sorry i used to work in movies
this is this is easy by comparison there
you go that's so you don't work this
like uh
14 hours days regularly well and this is
someone because i've also run
startups and most of the startups i ran
uh we worked our asses off you know what
i mean so like
it so there isn't like uh
there there isn't some something against
hard work i mean i love working hard
you know that was one of the funny
things about running for president on
universal basic income where people like
what about work and then like depending
upon my mood i would have responded
different ways but sometimes i'd be glib
and be like i'm asian i love work
people then you know
back off a little bit but but that that
is one of the fallacies right about the
ubi people say
oh you're just not going to work but i
feel like that's such a misunderstanding
of the human condition i mean nobody
just wants to
have no purpose in life i mean that's
that's outrageous
well this is the thing that that like
you know like makes makes you
laugh is like they'll say two things
simultaneously
one work is the most important element
of human life and without it we are lost
and two no one will want to do it if you
give them a little bit of money
right yeah that's great those two things
don't really come together it's like if
it's so crucial then wouldn't we do
it anyway maybe i think it's slightly
better
that's a great point i feel like also
the beautiful thing about ubi is that it
goes to everyone
at any different position that they are
in life so
you could be having a crisis you could
be having a meltdown
mental thing that doesn't allow you to
work right now you know you could be
having a physical injury that you can't
work right now even if you want to so
it reaches everyone at different
places in their life you know of course
yeah like it's
it's funny that you're just thinking
about this one situation where you're
healthy and you do want to work but
like you're not going to work because
you have money because you're getting a
thousand dollars
a month yeah what if you have an ailing
loved one what if you have a
young child or something or mental
illness or
no yeah like right now we have this
incredible the dynamic
or we have a yeah or you're in a
pandemic we have this homeless problem
homelessness problem that's just kind of
crushing
l.a right now and if you gave each
homeless person
uh if there was that bottoms you know
social safety net i think you would see
a lot
a lot less almost probably to zero in
terms of homelessness
you know now if you had that level of
resources you could reduce homelessness
very very
dramatically the issue it would be the
transition because some of the people
that are homeless right now
are have mental health problems or drug
addiction problems and then
and and don't may not even have a bank
account where it's not trying to send
you the money like
what's going on but over time if you
knew that everyone
had this money that they were entitled
to then you would reduce homelessness
pretty quickly because then it would
just look around and be like wait a
minute
like what's going on this person has got
like thousand dollars of
a year in value like you know i just did
to freaking
um make sure that it's actually uh
working for them
in a way and and to the extent that
people aren't in a position where
it would work for them because of their
own volition like it'd actually be
pretty straightforward to like help it
work for them where you'd have
like an organization being like every
homeless person i like bringing to the
shelter like we're gonna get thousands
of dollars
so like let's go get that done i mean
it's it is funny how market
market-driven everything
is in the u.s but if you give everyone
intrinsic value then all of a sudden
like
the market value starts kicking in for
people
well this is what i was running on
before was that i i knew that we'd been
conditioned to think that
we all needed to be economically
productive and then i said you know what
technology is going to
surpass our productivity in a lot of
these arenas
pretty quick and if we don't start
evaluating ourselves in a different way
then it's going to lead to disaster and
now we're seeing some version of it
um with the pandemic uh and so i think
universal basic income would very
quickly disentangle
uh this confusion the the
mixing of economic value and human value
because if you all just start getting
money for breathing for living for
existing
then you can start to feel like okay we
all have some worth that's independent
of
uh how much money i'm making at any
moment in time
and then that alone would humanize your
perspective really quickly
you know the other kind of nice thing i
like about the four day week is
something i i always thought about when
i was working in my
my desk job it's like
you pointed out this kind of uh
workaholic i think it's kind of in
israel it's the same you know in a lot
of
developed countries or around the world
i think people just
have this um overwhelming of pressure
social pressure to show how much
they care about their job by working
unreasonable hours
you know it's like in in europe i was
always
blown away by the fact that people get
like an entire month off you know and
there's august freaking everyone
disappears
i mean that that to me is is
unfathomable that uh
and then the thing that blew my mind is
when you learned that like
chinese new year even in china these
people people are getting a month off
and you don't see that are two months
off even in
no month off in america we don't have
that a little less than a month
we don't have that they travel back
their hometowns in many cases i think
it's less than a month but it's
significant though though their
work week i think is like the israeli
model of six days
oh really well so they work hard but the
thing is in israel too you don't have
that
well you get holidays but not like a
designated time off
and so to me it's like we we as human
beings
need to be defined by more than just our
jobs
now i think a four-day work week would
be a massive value out of the united
states but
i think that you know you wouldn't make
it one size fits all for every
organization because i've been parts of
some organizations where
you probably want to have you know like
a
a longer work schedule and there are
certain types of
roles and um where it makes sense but i
think as a default
setting where like the expectation is in
a four-day workweek i think would be
an incredible improvement in large part
because what you just said ethan which
is like what is the purpose of life
yeah is it our job or is it something
bigger uh that integrates a job includes
a job but it's not like exclusively
a job so uh
the four day work week is something that
to me would
actually make work like an appropriate
part of our lives right um you know uh
in a way that right now we have to be
honest that it's just creeping upwards
like it's it's going like from five
plus into like that zone uh
and i'm a data guy and there are very
very clear signs that
right now it's having a damaging effect
on our health
mental health stress levels
relationships family formation
and all of that stuff was pre-pandemic
um
the post in the pandemic uh
we just have to do anything we can to
give people
like a real sense of well-being
and even folks who are doing
well quote unquote like relatively
speaking during this time are not
exactly
like necessarily mentally
doing well you know there's just a lot
of
there's a lot of stress right now that i
think if you had
a couple of days a week or three days a
week where you were genuinely
disengaged from work it would be like
enormously helpful for so many of us
do you see yourself doing that
you know it's funny it's like it
certainly sounded like i was talking
about myself just then
um i mean for for me i'm in a similar
boat to you i think where
you know we're in a situation where
we're just trying to do positive things
and help people
like i'm very busy right now uh you know
i just spoke at the
dnc last night and then i went and
talked about my speaking at the dnc
later in the night so
uh you know we're distributing economic
relief like you we're working on this
data project where we're trying to get
people paid for their data
i'm helping these down and ballot
candidates who are running on universal
basic income because we got to try and
make it
happen for folks so i'm campaigning for
them all the time
campaigning for joe and kamala against
trump so i'm busier than ever and it's
cool
in the sense that like the world is on
fire and i i feel like
uh thanks to you and thanks to you some
other folks who believed in
in me like i feel like i've got
something of a fire extinguisher
yeah the world's on fire and i got a
fire extinguisher um
so like i better [ __ ] try and put the
fire out
you know it's like not everyone has a
fire extinguisher um it's just like you
guys where you looked up too you were
like wow there's a lot of freaking
need and suffering right now and like i
can help so you try to help like i'm in
the same boat you are
where this is a time for me to
like not worry too much about you know
like you know
my own uh like balance
i mean right i think it's different for
entrepreneurs or people who
manage i mean obviously
it's it's important but for people who
don't have much of a choice in the
matter you know we're expected to do
things
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you